MARK BENNETT: My
name is Mark Bennett.
And I'm actually very
new to Google Play.
I only joined the business
in January this year.
And well, what a
year's it's been.
Play is a very
exciting business.
I'm very humbled to see
some of those stories there.
And we have a very busy,
packed agenda today--
some incredibly cool
stuff that you're
going to hear more about today.
And my role is
pretty easy, really--
to talk about where Play and
Android are within the EMEA
region.
So let's get started,
and we'll start
by talking about our
platform-- about Android, which
is growing exponentially
over the last seven years
since it was launched.
And we announced an
amazing milestone that year
that we've passed 1 billion
active devices, which
is just an incredible number.
But what is also
a powerful number
is the 1.5 million activations
we are seeing every single day.
And that's a reflection of the
success of, obviously, Android
on smartphones and
tablets, but also
as Android has
continued to expand
onto other platforms, such
as Android TV, wearables,
and even into cars.
And as that ecosystem
is expanded,
so is the number of
OEMs we work with-- now
up to over 200 OEMs who are
developing for Android-- which,
again, is a huge number.
And then just to finish off the
ecosystem piece-- the operator
partnerships-- we're
working with carriers
across the world--
over 330 carriers
selling Android devices
and also enabling
Play customers to purchase.
And then in terms of share,
it's an equally powerful story.
We looked at the Android
share within the EMEA region
on smartphones.
And the great news
here is that that share
has increased since last year.
This is working with a research
company called Canalys.
And that share's gone
up from 72% to 77%.
So the momentum
is really with us.
And the story's good
on tablets as well--
three out of five tablets
in EMEA now run on Android.
So tremendous momentum.
And the future's bright.
The forecasts are
that smartphones
will double over
the next five years
to over 1.25 devices
in EMEA by 2019.
And as you can see, the
lion's share of that growth
is going to come from Android.
That's the big green
bit in the bar chart
there, in case you missed it.
So a very exciting few
years ahead as Android
continues to expand
into new markets.
And one area that is
particularly exciting
are these emerging markets.
Last year we talked
about Android One.
Our product director,
Michael Siliski,
introduced this
initiative that Google
was leading to try and drive
Android share into emerging
markets-- even with all the
growth I just talked about.
Only one out of four people on
this planet have a smartphone,
and Google's ambition is
to help that next 5 billion
also come online.
Android One is an
initiative-- we
work with OEMs,
chipset manufacturers--
to bring quality hardware
at a very low cost
into these emerging markets.
And the exciting thing, or
the most interesting thing
for you guys, in
terms of Android One,
is that the devices
have the latest
version of Android
on it, which we all
know is incredibly important.
We announced last
year that we were
bringing Android One to market.
And I'm delighted to say
that since then, we've
launched Android One in
India, Pakistan, Thailand,
Indonesia, the Philippines,
Nigeria, and Turkey.
And within EMEA, there's
significant continued expansion
as we bring Android One into
Egypt, Ghana, Kenya, Spain,
Morocco, and Egypt--
which I might have just
mentioned twice.
But the growth is fantastic.
And we're really excited to
see how Android One can bring
a really quality
experience at low cost
to even more users
in emerging markets.
So this scale--
this huge scale--
I think it's safe to say,
we're the biggest app platform
in the world.
Over 1 million apps
now live on the store.
And they've been downloaded a
phenomenal 50 billion times.
And Android users are
able to download your apps
in nearly 200 markets--
and importantly,
to pay for those
apps in 134 markets.
And payments, we know, is key.
Over the last 12 months,
we've added 61 new forms
of payments in 32
markets, which has enabled
over 400 million Android
users to now purchase on Play
with a new form of payment.
And we've expanded in
a number of key areas
to enable people to pay on
Play with different forms
of payment.
DCB is now in 37 markets,
up from 25 markets in 2014.
Just a couple of
weeks ago, we signed
a really big deal with a telco
called MTS in Russia that
now gives us virtually 100%
coverage for operated billing
in the Russian markets.
Gift cards are now live in
28 markets, from 18 in 2014.
And finally PayPal,
which we only switched on
early last year and is
now live in 21 markets.
And in markets like
Germany, that's
been a phenomenal driver
to help our growth.
And it was really pleasing to
see, in February this year,
App Annie talk about Google
Play being bigger in Germany
than Apple's App store.
So enabling payments helps
to enable the ecosystem.
And the good news is it's
paying off for our developers--
for you guys.
We announced that in 2014,
we paid out $7 billion
to our developer partners--
up from $5 billion in 2013,
and up from $2 billion in 2012.
And the momentum is still with
us with significant growth
as well.
So a very, very
bright picture indeed.
So you're going to
hear a lot today
about how we're continuing
to listen to you
and to build a better
platform for you
to distribute your apps, find
your users, and monetize.
And I'm just going to touch on
three of the key themes today--
enhanced discovery
opportunities-- how
we can help you find those
users within the app-- more
tools to help you
publish with confidence,
and making it easier to
help find and retain users.
So let's start with
enhanced discovery.
Play is about connecting
you with the Android
users that share the same
interests and passions
and needs as the products you're
building and taking to market.
And a key part of what
we do is try and make
our store experience
personalized and relevant,
so users keep coming in-- so
they're delighted that they're
finding the right apps and
games that really, really
excite them.
And the first area is to make
that store very personalized.
As we've started to really work
Google's expertise in machine
learning to make that a more
personalized experience--
to make those recommendations
come up as soon as a Play user
comes into the store.
And we'll building more
types of collections
and increasing more types
of personalization services,
because we know that doubles
the number of app installs,
by giving people
relevant recommendations.
We've also added guided search.
And this enables a Play
visitor to just search
for a broad generic term--
in this case, photography.
And what we then do is provide
them with relevant clusters,
bringing together
the types of apps
that you would expect
to see under a search
term like photography-- in
this case, photo editing
apps and collage apps.
And we know that
will introduce users
to a broader range of apps, and
therefore, increasing downloads
in a particular
search term like that.
And then finally,
an area that we're
quite interested in
seeing how it develops
is topic-based discovery.
Our sense is that users relate
much better to topics rather
than like, here's
some more apps that I
think are recommended to you--
bringing together clusters
under types of searches
popular for the weekend,
and games that are
going to make you laugh.
And we think that
will have a lot more
engagement with our users
on the store as well.
Families is a big
theme for Google.
You would have seen a lot going
on within Google around making
our products and services more
relevant to families and family
safety.
And that's absolutely the
case with Play, as well.
Before [? I/O, ?] we started
working with many of you
guys around [INAUDIBLE]
and submission
to have your apps categorized
within the family experience.
[? I/O ?] announced
that and you've now
seen this navigation appearing
within the store, allowing
parents to search by
different age categories,
by badges, even by
popular characters
to find the content
that's right for them
and right for the families.
This is a really
big step for us.
And we're seeing some
really huge numbers,
in terms of increased uplift in
apps that are within the family
browsing experience.
So if you have a family
app, please make sure it
is categorized within
this experience.
And besides making it
easier for our users
to find great apps
and games, we've
continued to listen to
you and build better tools
to enable you to publish,
acquire users, and
and more importantly, learn how
you can improve your products
to retain those users.
The list of tools and
features, you can see,
has got longer and
longer, year after year.
And you're going to hear a lot
more about really cool features
and functionalities that
we're bringing to market
to enable you to build better.
And one of the
consistent things I've
heard in the few months
I've been in the business
as I've spoken to developers
is the power of Play
to iterate, to put products
into market quickly,
to select groups of users,
and find out what's working
and what's not working
before you start
to spend money driving
acquisition to learn
the lessons around retention
before they come through.
And there's just three
examples, before I
get kicked off the stage,
that I wanted to highlight.
I had the pleasure
of going to see
the Wooga guys earlier on in the
year in their very cool offices
in Berlin.
And I know a couple of
the guys are here today.
Really pleasing to hear how
they're using beta testing,
staged rollouts-- again,
to learn more about
how users are enjoying the app
and where people are falling
out of their app as well.
And it's great to hear that
they're iterating first
on Android.
An app that you would've
seen in the video
at the beginning of today--
a really inspiring story
about Olivier, with RogerVoice,
to really revolutionize
telecommunications to allow
people who are hard of hearing
to have conversations.
He's used-- exactly
the same as Wooga--
to iterate first
on the platform.
And actually, he released
first on Android.
And then, finally,
a great case study
from one of our developers
in Russia, my.com,
with their great battle
game, Might and Glory.
Super to see them
launch first on Android.
So that's it from me.
I hope you've got another sense
of the scale and the success
and the excitement
of Play on Android.
The purpose of today is
to obviously give you
more information, but
also to listen to you
and to get more
feedback from how we can
make Play a better platform.
So, with that, I look forward
to meeting as many of you
as possible today.
And thank you for listening.
[CLAPPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]